a new source of friction between the two
countries several major newspapers
reported the man was suspected of
passing on information about the very
parliamentary committee investigating
the NSA spying operation a committee
whose meetings are supposed to be
confidential it's also reported the man
worked for Germany's Foreign
Intelligence Agency the BND German
parliamentarians are furious minzy the
isthmus suspicions of spying are true it
would be an unheard-of attack on our
parliamentary freedom and of our
democratic institutions in general
elementos would or could be absolutely
no justification for that Daffy lyptus
überhaupt kind of a strata gonk the
government was reportedly informed of
the allegation on Thursday this prompted
an immediate meeting of the
parliamentary Control Committee which
oversees the secret services is a guest
envisioned via we know since Thursday
about the serious allegations against a
German citizen the federal prosecutor
has taken on the case and the man is in
custody the federal criminal police have
been tasked with further investigations
should the charges be proven the case
would be a further blow to us German
relations